you ran a 266 on irving b
[Music]
yeah
just now
huh
[Music]
i thought it might dissuade him from
spending so much time with bert g
hey guys pete here today i'll be talking
about the fifth episode of severance
which continues to be my favorite thing
out there because it isn't afraid to
grapple with unpleasant realities like
that at the center of industry is dust i
think things made progress towards
coming into focus in the grim barbarity
of optics and design and i came away
from this episode thinking a lot more
about the motivations of the employees
who aren't severed plus bert irv and
dylan make a great trio and there were
baby goats i'll recap everything that
happened and what i think it might mean
right after this quick spoiler warning
if you haven't watched severance season
1 episode 5 yet then this video won't be
for you and with that out of the way
let's get into it
the opening sequence in the fifth
episode is a fantastic examination of
the transition from any to audi the
previous episode ended with heli's
resignation request being denied and her
making the decision to send the other
version of herself an offer she can't
refuse you see her hanging by the neck
making the shift from innie to audi as
the elevator goes up so that the ladder
struggles to get free as she realizes
she can't breathe elsewhere in the
basement mark looks pretty relaxed on
his way back from his wellness session
dylan is still in the office reading
ricken's book and he hides it on his lap
when mark walks by he goes to the
elevator and you see grainer running in
that direction at the same time mark
finds heli hanging limp when the door
opens he holds her and takes her down
and you can see that she's still
breathing greaner forces him to get into
the elevator and he shifts to his audi
mode forgetting what he just walked away
from the next morning you see this in
reverse as he shifts to being terrified
about what happened to his co-worker
milcheck and koble are waiting there for
him to arrive to his surprise harmony
tells him that her audi has no intention
of resigning and that she'll be back in
her desk in a few days she warns him
that this happened on his watch and says
he can thank keir himself that it worked
out the way it did this sets up a
montage where mark is reading the book
over the next couple of days the quotes
are fairly hilarious and it looks like
his any brain is gobbling them right up
my favorite line was a society with
festering workers cannot flourish just
as a man with rotting toes cannot skip
but they were all pretty good with a
perfect reading and delivery in her
office greener tells koble that they ran
the diagnostics on petey's chip he tells
her that they found full synaptic
coupling pd's memory was reintegrated
there's mention of her waiting before
telling the board because of what just
happened with helly and he realizes she
hasn't told him about that yet she wants
to find out who reintegrated petey so
that she can take all the information to
them at once audi mark gets messages
from ricken telling him his sister is
going into labor in an effort to create
a soul void because the fetus is drawn
to clean air ricken shares the secret
that he's upset that mark hasn't called
to thank him for his book yet because he
never got it they think it must have
been stolen devin goes to grab coffee
leaving them alone together and giving
them a chance to hang kelp she sees
another pregnant woman in the really big
inexpensive cabin next door so she goes
there to ask for coffee and gets invited
inside by a new character whose name is
gabby devin asked if she's rich and
considering this feels like a company
town you have to wonder if she isn't
married to someone high up at lumen
maybe even someone who's on the board we
don't find out anything right at this
point but it seems like this character
will come back one way or the other when
it's time to tell a secret the next time
mark tells devin he thinks lumen might
be up to something he starts to tell her
about petey but before he really gets
any information out she starts to have
the baby while that's happening you see
that the phone is still ringing in the
box at his place and that he does think
about petey's last moments when he saw
him fall down outside the store
back at the office milcheck explains to
mark that helie was in audi form when
she woke up so when she comes down this
time it'll be the innies first conscious
experience since the hanging and she
does wake up freaked out in the elevator
he assures her that they locked away the
extension cords and other dangerous
items so she'd be safe and lets her know
that if she wants to look for happy
numbers for a while that's fine when he
asks her if she wants to talk about it
she just walks away irv thinks they
should try to help her by hiding
inspirational handbook quotes around the
office for her to stumble upon dylan
thinks she just needs to start earning
perks because he knows he would end his
life if he didn't have his finger traps
management has sent miss casey she's
there to watch hely and help her forego
any future suicide attempts upon request
she can even offer a hug and dylan
throws it out there that he's been
exhibiting signs of sadness but she
shoots his request down she sits right
behind helly and takes notes on
everything that she does during this
period we see irv start to doze off
again where he sees the black goo
dripping from the ceiling when mark
looks over and says his name he pictures
him with goo coming out of one of his
eyes so that's probably something to
remember when he wakes up he says he
needs to go to ond and this sets off a
sequence of events that all felt like
they were bringing us closer to
understanding what is happening on the
severed floor when he goes to the copy
machine it spits out a color painting of
the violent coup dylan brought up a few
episodes ago while he's looking at that
milcheck comes in and says that he sent
them to the wrong printer by mistake and
that irv wasn't supposed to see them he
brushes it off as nothing saying it's
just a joke for miss koble irv
recognizes them as the coup and asked
milcheck if it really happened he says
of course not nothing like that could
happen here and when he goes back to his
office miss coble refers to it as a 266.
milchak says he thought it might
dissuade him from spending so much time
with bert g then when he questions her
about sending miss casey to watch helly
she responds with the quote the light of
discovery shines truer on a virgin
meadow than a beaten path she says that
she's trying something new with miss
casey and tells him to keep it between
the two of them so there is a
coordinated effort to keep the severed
departments from fraternizing with each
other and you see how this works when
miss casey tells irv that bert is in the
conference room he goes there right away
to ask bert what he's doing and while
he's explaining that he was just looking
for him because he hadn't seen him dylan
comes up and takes off his belt to lock
bert in irv freaks out and when he can't
find mark and helly he comes back and
asks bert if he knows what happened to
them we've known what dylan thinks about
o and d and then we saw the painting
which gave us an idea of where that came
from and from bert we learned that they
don't trust mdr either they have their
own set of things that they don't like
and it involves them having pouches that
they can carry their young in their
larval offspring that will jump out an
attack if you get too close to them and
even though this is a joke the sentiment
holds they don't like each other he also
adds that the larva eventually eats and
replaces you saying that that would
explain irving's youthful energy and at
this point dylan realizes that they have
feelings for each other and he does not
approve because he's been conditioned
not to trust them why it's important to
keep the department suspicious of each
other isn't clear and this is something
i'll come back to at the end they escort
bert back to omd with his hands tied
behind his back with dylan's belt
there's talk about how relationships
beyond the platonic are frowned upon and
bert asked if that's what they are irv
never gives him an answer to this and
they go inside to appreciate a painting
of keir meeting his wife at the factory
they both worked at and that gives irv
another chance to deliver one of his
perfectly timed care quotes when he says
they took heart to each other as
colleagues dylan finds what he thinks is
the same painting from the printout but
they realize that the roles are actually
reversed in this version and instead of
being called the grim barbarity of
optics and design where the episode gets
its name this one is called the macro
data refinement calamity and this makes
the employees question why would there
be two versions of the same painting
mark and helly take a mental health
break field trip after she washes the
makeup off that her audi covered the
marks on her neck with and he spilled
his coffee to get miss casey out of the
room she isn't receptive to anything
that he has to say at first and she
leads him into parts of the floor we
hadn't seen yet eventually she comes
clean about how her audi telling her she
wasn't a person set her off mark tries
to tell her not to focus on her and asks
what she wants in here the innie and she
tells him what i want is for her to wake
up as the life drains out of her body
and to know it was me who did it before
he can respond to that they're
interrupted to what sounds like a baby
crying they realize that it's coming
from a baby goat and they follow it into
a room where they see a man in a suit
feeding them and them is there's a bunch
of them running around he tells them
they're not ready you can't take them
and then he tells them to get the hell
out of there on their way out she
continues her role of being the audience
surrogate by asking a question that
would inevitably pass through every
viewer's mind i mean what if the goats
are the numbers is this department
connected some way into what they're
doing mark tells her that he knows that
she doesn't want to be there but he's
glad that she is and then she says that
she'll clean up the map for him and
they'll continue petey's work as miss
casey finds them and is glad to find out
they're both unhurt we see that miss
koble is watching all of this play out
on her monitor greener comes in to ask
her if she's aware of what they're up to
right now and wonders why she's not
stopping it she pulls out another key
quote saying the surest way to tame a
prisoner is to let him believe he's free
greener acknowledges that there's a cure
quote for everything and wonders how
many departments she's going to let them
find she doesn't say but says that he
can talk to her when he finds out who
hacked kilmer's chip back at o and d
burt brings irv and dylan into the back
room and introduces them to everyone as
being from mdr and says that they're
friends the episode comes to an end with
him scanning the other employees for
reactions as irv is beaming and dylan is
suspicious behind him
i thought this was another dynamite
installment although i did find myself
less engaged with the birthing retreat
situation things that happen in the real
world to audi mark feel a little less
vital than what goes on at the office
it's not bad rickon is fun and i did
feel like this gabby character was
leading somewhere but it has trouble
matching the office stuff which is just
so sharp mark and helly are becoming a
team i suppose that makes sense because
petey was his best friend and also seems
kind of inevitable in hindsight
considering how much he got on her
nerves in the beginning i do still think
her transition probably isn't that much
different than what the other people in
mdr experienced when they first started
then again this situation at the
beginning and knowing she chose to try
to end her life to get back at her audi
make her feel that and know it came from
this entity that she didn't consider a
person that's probably on the extreme
end of things and that's gonna be hard
to top dehumanization is something
people often do but in this case it's
part of yourself and she's fully aware
and making a choice this has led to a
lot of theories about her audi being
someone important a member of the eagan
family a careerist on the way up
something along those lines but i'm not
really sold on that it's possible but i
think there are similarities between her
inny and audi and i find the idea of
these people making the choice to
participate in this program fascinating
in and of itself irv and bert are on the
forbidden love path and it's a whole lot
of fun watching these two actors play
off each other it's clever how their
appreciation for keir corporate
mythology is what draws them together
enough to overcome the department divide
there was a popular theory out there
that bert was trying to bring irv in to
be one of those permanently severed
employees that pedia was talking about
but i think after this episode that
falls apart they seem like our example
of what happens when innies wake up to
their human need for companionship and
plus the horniness there are a few
lingering questions around like who
hacked petey's chip and is mark ever
going to answer his phone is the work
they do actually important and did the
baby goats move the needle in one
direction or the other how many
departments do we think there are and
what's going on with the black goo will
mdr and ond form an alliance and is that
something that's happened before as i
mentioned in the beginning i came away
more focused on kobold milchek and
greener the unsevered also miss casey
continues to be weird and i can't say i
know what to think about her i saw a few
people wondering if she's a robot and i
can at least see where they got that
idea initially i thought there might be
some amount of genuine care in the mrs
selvig-mark relationship but now i think
she's just a lumen super soldier she has
more quotes than ervin burke combined
and they have an excuse for always using
them the idea that they're employing
techniques to keep the employees from
getting close has me wondering what is
the overall goal what are they trying to
accomplish limited experience with other
people would foster loyalty to the
organization if that's all you have at
your disposal the way rickens contraband
book is being devoured by everyone is a
great example of this do they need an
agenda beyond that i'm not sure creating
a cult of workers is something in itself
and it makes me wonder how long they've
been trying to accomplish that and what
other methods they would have tried
before they had these implants at their
disposal that's kind of where my mind
keeps wandering i mean it could be for
profit marketing the technology it could
be a psychological experiment but when i
think about how devoted miss coble seems
to be without ever having the procedure
done thinking of things like that
strange wall hanging in her living room
and the whole taking the drill to
petey's wake and pulling the chip out
maybe they're just trying to have
everyone in their offices that dedicated
i really don't know but i'm excited to
see where it goes from here and i think
that's a good place to leave things let
me know in the comments all the
questions you have after this episode
what you're hoping to see in the next
one and your theories about what's
happening and where you think it's going
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and thanks for watching
i'll talk to you soon